former Vice President Joe Biden now has
a clear route to the Democratic
presidential nomination his last
opponent senator Bernie Sanders
suspended his campaign yesterday he told
supporters his path to victory was
virtually impossible his words and
continuing his campaign would interfere
with the fight against the coronavirus
is Ed O'Keefe reports the Vermont
independent is still focused on
defeating President Trump we are you
know talking to Joe and we're talking to
his team about how we can work together
last night senator Bernie Sanders told
Stephen Colbert he would do everything
he could to stop President Trump but
stop short of a full-throated
endorsement for Joe Biden you thought
Collor I got my platform I got that all
right but if he can move in that
direction I think people say you know
what this is a guy who we should support
the road to victory for Sanders had
already been blocked by simple math and
then exacerbated by the coronavirus
Sanders trails the former vice president
by more than 300 delegates the pandemic
put a stop to campaign rallies and any
hope of breaking through I have
concluded that this battle for the
Democratic nomination will not be
successful but Sanders plans to keep his
name on the ballot in states that have
yet to hold primary contests in hopes of
influencing the party's 2020 platform
his leadership is going to continue
including working to address the
incredible challenges were now facing
and wide and we spoke to Sanders
Wednesday acknowledged the Senators
appeal to younger voters he didn't just
run a political campaign he created a
movement and that's a good thing for the
nation and for our future Biden advisers
now believe the contest against
President Trump will come down to an
argument over competence experience
compassion and empathy mr. Trump's
reelection campaign on Wednesday
released this ad trying to link Biden to
Sanders they're more alike than you
think
as the presumptive nominee Biden can now
start focusing on picking a running mate
his team is expected to begin the formal
vetting process in the coming days we
also expect a formal endorsement from
Biden's former boss former President
Barack Obama some point soon Anthony
all right dad thank you